La oferta educativa de Quebec es de muy
alta calidad y viene a un precio a un
costo que es sumamente competitivo. El francés como lengua de aprendizaje, de
estudios, así como lengua de trabajo en
el futuro es una ventaja competitiva
para una persona. Así que estudiar en
Quebec ofrece muchos muchas ventajas
además de la calidad de vida, la
seguridad cuando uno está estudiando
allá,  pero también para porque el
bagaje profesional para un joven que va
a estudiar a Quebec y que regresa con
las herramientas de una educación de muy
alta calidad, un alto nivel de francés. Ésto le va a apoyar durante toda su
carrera. Lo que tiene que saber es que
hay unos pasos que se tienen que seguir
para estudiar en Quebec, que no son tan
complicados pero uno tiene que pensarlo
bien. Todo este proceso
normalmente lleva de ocho a nueve meses
así se tiene que pensar con anticipación
y preparar la cosa.